hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
going to be my explanation for the
ending of Batman vs Superman just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it Zack Snyder's been talking about how
things are going to work in Justice
League part 1 so here we go so a lot of
you probably walked away from the movie
having a pretty good sense for the way
things are going to play out it's just a
question of timeline Superman winds up
in the ground but we all know that he
comes back from the dead or seemingly
from the dead things largely play out
just like the death of Superman arc in
the comics written by Dan Jergens who is
actually like the new writer on Action
Comics now because of the DC rebirth
stuff that's completely separate I'll
explain what's going on with Superman in
the comics at the end of the video
because it has nothing to do with what's
going on in the movies but way back in
the 90s during the death of superman arc
and in the movie Batman V Superman
doomsday seemingly kills Superman or we
should say Superman seemingly dies
saving the world from doomsday they both
end up coming back and beating the
out of each other several times over the
years because comics of course that's
why I love comics but generally the way
they use doomsday in the comics is a
little bit different than the way the
movies used him you can see the way the
world was treating Superman during
Batman V Superman like do I help people
if I help people I wind up hurting all
these other people there was that weird
scene with PAS Kent the hallucination
where he's like Clark I saved our farm
but then Lana Lang's farm downstream
ended up getting flooded and I had to
hear all the calves screaming in my
dreams while I was eating my victory
cake that was pretty haunting the only
way for Superman to win in this scenario
is to take himself out of the equation
so he kills himself saving the world and
that will forever prove to everyone that
he is on their side look he killed
himself to save you all maybe he's not
here to hurt you so the big big problem
that he faces during Batman vs Superman
has been solved the second big problem
is Lex Luthor's comment at the end the
Bell has been rung it can't be unrung
then it goes to the shot of the painting
with the angel standing over the
battlefield a lot of you were asking me
what that painting meant and I don't
know if it's Michelangelo I couldn't
find if it's actually a painting in real
life with the way Lex Luthor interprets
it at the beginning of the movie is
different
the way Zack Snyder uses it at the end
of the movie the devil doesn't come from
below the devil comes from above so the
devil at the beginning of the movie is
Lex Luthor explains it is Superman the
red capes are coming as in Superman is
going to become this super leader of the
entire world where it's going to turn
into an injustice situation where he
becomes something of a tyrant but at the
end of the movie when they go back to
that painting they mean Tamir that
thought theater the devil comes from the
sky because we know about the flash
coming back in warning Bruce Wayne to
assemble the Justice League find them he
says find them Bruce we know that the
devil from the sky is dark side now we
don't really know what he's going to
actually look like in Justice League
part one I really hope they don't do the
Batman vs Superman thing where they
reveal what Darkseid looks like up front
but essentially what Zack Snyder is
saying using this imagery is that there
will be a new threat from space coming
from above Darkseid and the legions of
apocalypse that is why at the end of the
movie when Batman says to Wonder Woman
please help me find these other
metahumans we need to stand together and
she's like you know what what makes you
think that they would do that he says oh
I have a feeling we're gonna need to it
is kind of a cheesy throwaway line but
he's saying that we need to assemble the
Justice League because Darkseid is
coming now he doesn't know what
Darkseid's name is he just knows that
is going to get crazy and they're
going to need everybody they can get so
even if you haven't read The Death of
Superman arc you know that he just he
goes away for a while on the comics and
then comes back after an event called
the reign of the Superman where a whole
bunch of people come back claiming to be
Superman and then eventually the real
Superman rias now here's where Zack
Snyder explains the creation of the
Justice League he says he wanted Batman
to have to do it by himself without the
help of Superman I mean technically he
does have Wonder Woman's help and she is
a fully fledged hero but he didn't want
them to have Superman's help because
when you have a god going around telling
other people there's a threat coming you
must join me so that we can save the
earth it is a lot easier to get people
to help you so in order to make it a
little more difficult make it a little
more interesting
Batman is going to have to go around and
try to put the Justice League together
by himself so what I'm thinking is is
that Justice League part 1 will be that
story for most that movie he'll be going
around Walter Matthau trying to put the
bad news bears together and then at the
end of that
be some big WTF Superman will come back
and then the Justice League part 2 movie
will be the story of how they all come
together to defeat Darkseid now a lot of
you especially the comic-book readers
are asking how the hell is Superman
going to come back in the movies there's
no Fortress of Solitude
there's no Kryptonian tech to
supercharge him with solar energy it's
either going to have to happen the
old-fashioned way or they're going to
have to take his body to Silas stone at
STAR Labs so I'm not really expecting a
reign of the Superman arc from the
comics what I'm thinking is is that in
assembling the Justice League he'll
learn about all the fancy toys that they
have at STAR Labs and that will be part
of how they bring Superman back now they
still have a lot of Kryptonian tech if
they have a mother box that's going to
help create cyborg they'll still have
some Kryptonian tech so they'll find a
way to juice Superman's body with solar
energy that will bring him the rest of
the way back just like in the comics
when doomsday seemingly killed him I
think it's the same deal in the movie
where his body isn't technically dead
he's just on the edge of death if he
took a nuclear blast to the face and
then came back within the span of like
two minutes in a movie then it's going
to take a lot more than a bone sword
through the chest to kill him so all
things being equal I'll just guess and
say that for like the first third of
Justice League part 1 he's going to stay
in the ground in that casket in
Smallville till they figure out oh wait
maybe he's not completely dead we should
try to bring him back so happy Easter
Christ is totally coming back from the
dead don't you love the Christ metaphors
from Superman even if it's not a
religious film Superman always comes
with all these heavy-handed religious
themes which i think is kind of funny
christ died and then three movies later
he came back from the dead let's
actually let's count that so what's next
there's Suicide Squad that's one movie
there's one woman right after that and
then Justice League makes three movies
so Christ dies then three movies later
he comes back but let me know in the
comments how do you think Superman is
going to come back do you think that
STAR Labs is going to use some
Kryptonian tech to find a way to
supercharge his body it's going to have
to involve solar energy and there's no
Fortress of Solitude in the movies right
now so I think maybe by the end of like
Justice League part two we'll probably
get a version of the watchtower we might
get a version of the fortress of
solitude but what's going to happen
tonight is there'll be a new episode of
The Walking Dead there actually is a new
round of the DC giveaway so I should
say all you have to do to enter that is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video it's just for to IMAX gift
certificates for the movie I'll keep
doing that through next week
but new Walking Dead tonight I just
posted a big trailer video for negan
he's going to be coming really soon so a
lot of really awesome comic book related
things happening right now while you
guys wait for me to post that video you
can click here for all my Batman V
Superman Easter eggs and you can click
here for my review of the movie thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you